[Música]
economía en directo América me acompaña
en el estudio Juan Pablo lucumir Juan
Pablo muy buenas noches comenzamos
hablando de los ganadores del premio
Nobel de ciencias económicas Cuál fue su
hallazgo así de Santiago Buenas noches
pues ganaron por su investigación sobre
las quiebras bancarias en la década de
los 80 el premio fue para beber quien
fue presidente de la reserva Federal de
Estados Unidos desde 2006 a 2014 y para
otros dos economistas radicados en
Estados Unidos ellos tres estudiaron los
errores de la gran depresión de 1929 y
1930 y según el panel del garaldón sus
estudios sentaron las bases para regular
los mercados en la crisis financiera de
2008 que hizo el entonces presidente de
la Fed que hoy se le aplaude pues número
uno se asoció con el departamento del
tesoro de Estados Unidos para aliviar la
escasez de crédito dos recortó las tasas
de interés de corto plazo a 0 y
estableció programas de préstamos sin
precedentes todo este paquete según los
expertos permitió calmar inversionistas
en aquella crisis escuchémoslo con sus
propias palabras
de 2006 a 2014 estuve involucrado en una
crisis financiera global donde los
problemas en el sector financiero
causaron enormes problemas en la
economía real
[Música]
aquí y en todo el mundo y pensar en
estos problemas me hizo muy decidido
hacer todo lo que pudiera junto con mis
otros formuladores de políticas mis
colegas para tratar de evitar que el
sistema financiero se derrumbase
Juan Pablo seguimos hablando de este
Premio Nobel de ciencias económicas pero
pasemoslo a las cifras Cuántas personas
lo han ganado Santiago pues mire se ha
otorgado 54 veces entre 1969 y 2022 92
individuos han sido galardonados y el
nuevo oportunidades contando la actual
se ha entregado a un trío Solo dos
mujeres lo han ganado en la historia una
de ellas es la más joven en recibir el
premio Esther dolfo en 2019 cuando tenía
46 años de edad importante destacaban la
región Juan Pablo ese cambio de gabinete
de ministros en Argentina de quién se
trata Pues seguimos hablando de mujeres
porque en esta vez fueron tres mujeres
las que el presidente Alberto grandes
involucró a su gabinete para hacer jefas
de cartera de importantes asuntos en el
sector laboral y social se trata de
Victoria tolosa Paz cercana al
presidente Y quién es diputada del
oficialista frente de todos ella quedó
como ministra de desarrollo ayelén
masina una que pues es poco menos
conocida públicamente quedó encargada
del Ministerio de mujeres géneros y
diversidad y Raquel Olmos quien quedó
como jefa de la cartera de trabajo Esta
última por ejemplo deberá lidiar con los
problemas de la alta informalidad en el
país y las constantes presiones de los
sindicatos en las negociaciones
salariales en un contexto de la
elevadísima inflación que lo hemos
hablado acá que pues recordemos expertos
prevén que supere el 100% para fin de
año y le doy un dato con estas tres que
acaban de incorporar con estas tres
ministras el número de mujeres en el
gabinete de Fernández asciende a 4 de
las 19 carteras que tiene el país Juan
Pablo Ya hablábamos del tema en el
bloque de noticias del El combustible en
Francia profundicemos Qué es lo que está
pasando allí pues Recién llegada de
Argelia la ministra de la primera
ministra de francesa Elizabeth born se
encontró con un panorama que pues casi
un tercio de las estaciones del país
presentan una escasez de combustible y
realizó una reunión de emergencia con
otros cuatro ministros esto debido a las
constantes huelgas de los trabajadores
quienes exigen un incremento salarial
los empleados de total energys Ya
entraron en su tercera semana de
protestas y las huelgas de las empresas
eso y exo móvil tampoco se detendrán
como es de esperarse muchos franceses
temen que la poca gasolina que queda se
acabe pero las autoridades han hecho un
llamado para no dar pues no llegar al
pánico y que ellos empiecen a
abastecerse de combustible pues esto es
lo único que hace Es que empeore la
situación esto Dijo la primera ministra
antes de la reunión de emergencia
realmente quiero que todo se unan a las
discusiones es a través de negociaciones
entre la dirección y los representantes
de los trabajadores que deberíamos poder
encontrar una solución No bloqueando el
país o paralizando los franceses espero
que la situación se resuelva lo antes
posible podemos ver que muchos hombres y
mujeres franceses están siendo
penalizados por estas huelgas
Juan Pablo indicadores como les falles
principales bolsas en la jornada de hoy
pues estamos de nuevo en números rojos
como en septiembre Wall Street cerró con
sus tres principales indicadores en
terreno negativo nasdaq registró su
cierre más bajo desde julio de 2020 en
medio del temor de los inversores por
las elevadas tasas de interés y tras
conocerse que Estados Unidos empezaría a
obstaculizar la industria de
semiconductores de China el informe de
empleos del viernes pasado todavía sigue
en las Mentes de los compradores y
también afectó los resultados del
mercado las bolsas europeas siguieron la
senda negativa de Estados Unidos luego
de conocerse los más recientes
bombardeos en Ucrania y los polémicos
sucesos de escasez de combustible en
Francia como acabamos de hablar y en
nuestra región pues completa el panorama
negativo este lunes con la bolsa de
valores de México y la de Sao Paulo de
Brasil con sus principales indicadores
con leves pérdidas Muchas gracias Juan
Pablo por esta actualización es todo por
el momento aquí en la economía en
directo América a continuación el debate
[Música]